la mañana de hoy se desata un incendio
el parlamento sudafricano ubicado en
ciudad del cabo apenas a una cuadra de
la catedral de san jorge donde hace 24
horas se daba se llevaba a cabo el
funeral del arzobispo desmond tutu el
incendio empezó en horas de la mañana y
durante la mañana y las tempranas horas
de la tarde empezó a entenderse desde
las áreas de las oficinas a otras áreas
del edificio y según los bomberos unos
60 bomberos que se encuentran acá
tratando de controlar las llamas no ha
habido víctimas pero sí se han
presentado graves daños estructurales
algunos de los techos de estos antiguos
edificios se han caído y también se han
presentado algunas grietas en algunas de
las paredes que podrían eventualmente
colapsar
recordemos que algunos de esos edificios
anuncian bastante antigua ciudad del
cabo- tiene un patrimonio arquitectónico
es muy rico algunas estructuras se
remontan al siglo 19 y también
recordemos que en abril del 2021 se
presentó un incendio muy grande en la
biblioteca la universidad del cabo
causando la pérdida de miles de
manuscritos y también algunos graves
daños estructurales
por otra parte el edificio del
parlamento sudafricano es también un
emblema de la democracia en el país es
donde se redactó y donde se adoptó la
nueva constitución dando paso a la nueva
democracia sudafricana así que desde la
era era era parte es una piedra angular
en la memoria histórica y arquitectónica
de este país
el presidente cyril ramaphosa también
que se encontraba en la ciudad por el
funeral de desmon tutú ha visitado el
lugar del incendio y ha declarado
también que se están adelantando las
investigaciones incluyendo algunos
interrogatorios para determinar cuáles
fueron las causas de este incendio